un estudiante de enfermería me acaba de
mandar este problema y yo creo que es
fundamental que los enfermeros puedan
convertir unidades sobre todo si yo soy
el paciente así que como el problema me
pareció interesante y creo que es
bastante útil vamos a resolverlo el
problema dice así un doctor receta la
medicina x le voy a poner aquí doctor
doctor
receta receta la medicina x medicina
medicina x y el doctor dice que la dosis
le voy a poner aquí que en la dosis con
otro color la dosis
de esta medicina debe de ser de 5
miligramos 5 miligramos por libra que
pese el paciente o sea 5 miligramos de
medicina x por libra que pese el
paciente cada 12 horas
12 x
muy bien sin embargo nosotros como
enfermeros en el inventario no
encontramos la medicina x así sólida si
no la encontramos en una solución y esa
solución tiene cierta concentración que
está dada en gramos por mililitro
entonces déjame escribir eso aquí abajo
o sea lo que tenemos en inventario le
voy a poner así en color rojo medicina
medicina x en inventario inventario
es una solución o sea es un líquido de
0.9 gramos por mililitro gramos de
medicina x por mililitro de solución
vale entonces básicamente si yo le doy
un mililitro de solución al paciente le
estoy dando puntos 9 gramos de medicina
x tenemos esta información y tenemos una
más además nos dicen el peso del
paciente
entonces le voy a poner aquí que el
paciente en realidad es la masa verdad
pero se entiende la idea que el paciente
tiene un peso de 72 72 puntos 7
kilogramos kilogramos esto es toda la
información que nos dan y la pregunta
que nos hacen es la siguiente la
pregunta es cuántos mililitros hay que
darle a este paciente para cada una de
sus dosis entonces lo voy a escribir
aquí voy a poner mililitros cuántos
mililitros para el paciente
paciente paciente por
dosis dosis entonces claramente este es
un problema de conversión de unidades y
vamos a tener que hacer un montón de
conversiones vamos a tener que pasar el
peso del paciente o bien a libras o la
dosis a miligramos por kilo y luego los
miligramos a gramos y los gramos a
mililitros y vamos a tener que hacer un
montón de cuentas vale pero bueno va a
estar divertido y va a ser muy útil
entonces vamos paso a paso para no
confundirnos ahora una información
adicional que vamos a requerir además de
todo esto es la tasa de conversión entre
kilogramos y libras estas son unidades
de distintos sistemas los kilogramos son
del sistema métrico las libras del
sistema inglés entonces es bueno saber
convertir entre un sistema y el otro
porque no es tan fácil como aprenderse
prefijos como en el sistema en el
sistema métrico vale entonces voy a
poner aquí al lado esa información para
tenerla en cuenta entonces tenemos que
un kilogramo un kilogramo es
aproximadamente igual a 2.2
libras si quisiéramos ser más exactos
por no sé por qué por lo de las dosis y
así podríamos buscarlo en una tabla pero
bueno esta aproximación es es suficiente
para ahorita y también sabemos que una
libra una libra es aproximadamente igual
a 0.45 kilogramos kilogramos muy bien
entonces estoy acá son las tasas de
conversión entre sistema métrico y
sistema inglés va déjame poner el
cuadrito listo entonces con esto ya
tenemos toda la información para
meternos a las matemáticas y hacer las
cuentas que necesitamos entonces lo
primero que vamos a hacer es pasar esta
dosis de miligramos de medicina por
libra de paciente a miligramos de
medicina por kilogramos de paciente esto
lo voy a hacer para que ya todo quede en
el sistema métrico entonces déjame
empezar con esta con esta dosis de 5
miligramos
gramos por libra por libra y la quiero
convertir a miligramos por kilogramo
entonces para esto aquí voy a poner
libras en el numerador y voy a dividir
entre kilogramos y aquí tenemos la
conversión tenemos que que un kilogramo
un kilogramo es igual a 2.2 libras es
igual a 2.2 libras y aquí te puedes
preguntar cómo supe que libras iba
arriba kilogramos abajo que el 2.2 será
multiplicado y no dividido
bueno pues puse libras arriba para que
se cancelarán con estas libras con las
libras que teníamos en el denominador y
en el denominador nos quedara kilogramos
vale y el 2.2 va arriba porque justo esa
es la tasa que nos da aquí tenemos que
poner libras con 2.2 para que esto sea
un 1 y la expresión inicial no se
modifique entonces vamos a hacer la
cuenta tenemos 5 por 2.2 5 por 12 10 5
por punto 2 es uno entonces nos queda
igual a 11 11 miligramos
por kilogramo muy bien entonces son 11
miligramos de medicina x por dosis por
cada kilogramo que pesa el paciente muy
bien ya todo lo tenemos en sistema
métrico ahora lo que voy a hacer es
pasar en vez de 1000
es pasar estos miligramos a gramos para
en vez de tener miligramos voy a poner
gramos para que después podamos pasar a
mililitros entonces déjame multiplicar
ahora por algo que convierte a estos
miligramos en gramos otra vez como ya
hacemos para pensar en esto para pensar
en esto queremos cancelar los miligramos
entonces hay que dividir hay que dividir
entre miligramos entre miligramos y
arriba queremos que nos queden gramos
que números tenemos que poner aquí pues
a ver un gramo un gramo son mil
miligramos mil miligramos vale entonces
arriba va un gramo abajo va mil
miligramos no cambia la expresión pero
si cambian las unidades miligramos se
cancela con miligramos y esto nos queda
igual
11 11 entre 1000 entre 1000
gramos de medicina x por cada kilogramo
que pese el paciente en cada dosis vale
bueno entonces ya tenemos esto en gramos
por kilo gramos pero ahora tenemos que
pasar a la solución verdad porque lo que
tenemos en él en el inventario es un
líquido no es polvito de medicina x si
no es una cierta solución con esta
concentración déjame poner aquí abajo
esto otra vez lo voy a poner con color
verde entonces voy a poner 11 entre mil
3.000 gramos por kilogramo entonces
ahora debemos hacer algo para pasar esto
a mililitros entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer aquí es multiplicar por algo que
nos cancele los gramos como gramos esto
en el numerador ahora lo voy a poner en
el denominador y queremos que arriba nos
quede mililitros para tener la dosis en
mililitros mililitros por kilogramo
entonces que tenemos que número tenemos
que poner aquí pues hay que tener
cuidado 'ocean nova' éste 0.9 si no va
su inverso porque éste está en gramos
por mililitro pero aquí tenemos
mililitros por gramo entonces déjame
multiplicar por 1 entre 0.9 sale
entonces gramos ya se logra cancelar con
gramos y ya nos queda mililitros entre
kilogramo y esto es igual a voy a
cambiar de color esto es igual a 11 11
entre 1000 por punto 9 mil por puntos 9
900 de una vez hago la multiplicación
900 mililitros mililitros de solución la
que tenemos en el inventario por
kilogramo por kilogramo que pese el
paciente todavía no terminamos verdad
porque queremos los mililitros para el
paciente por dosis pero lo que tenemos
son los mililitros por kilogramo por
dosis entonces todavía tenemos que
multiplicar esta expresión por algo que
nos cambie los kilogramos a paciente no
cualquier paciente sino este paciente
que pesa 72 puntos 7 kilogramos cómo le
hacemos pues tenemos que multiplicar por
saber queremos cancelar kilogramos
entonces ahora lo ponemos en el
numerador
y queremos que aparezca en el
denominador paciente
paciente para que tengamos los
mililitros por paciente no cualquier
paciente sino este paciente o bueno
cualquiera que pese 72 puntos 7
kilogramos
entonces cómo está la equivalencia pues
un paciente un paciente bueno el
paciente pesa 72 72 punto 7 kilogramos
muy bien ya nada más déjame reescribir
esto un poco más bonito kilogramos se
cancela con kilogramos nos queda 11 por
72 puntos 7 11 por 72.7 dividido entre
900 entre 900 mililitros por paciente
paciente mililitros por paciente en cada
dosis vale bueno aquí tenemos números
grandes y complicados y como no queremos
equivocarnos en la dosis haciendo las
cuentas a mano déjame sacar la
calculadora entonces voy a sacar la
calculadora para hacer esta operación es
11 x 72.7 11 x
72.7 eso es igual pues casi a 800 799
punto 7 y eso lo tenemos que dividir
entre 900 y eso es igual a 0.8 885 lo
voy a redondear a 0.8 cientos 89 no creo
que le importe al médico
entonces 0.8 189 va entonces esto de
aquí es igual
déjame ponerlo ya con un color brillante
no porque ya es la respuesta a la buena
entonces es 0 punto 889 mililitros
mililitros para el paciente para el
paciente
en cada dosis
cada
dosis
muy bien entonces ya transformamos estos
5 miligramos por libra a información que
tiene que ver con el paciente cero punto
889 mililitros para el paciente en cada
dosis muy bien y bueno esta información
de que la dosis era cada 12 horas
como te decía en realidad estaba además
si supiéramos o no sé si quisiéramos
determinar la cantidad total de solución
para dos días de tratamiento pues como
12 horas caben cuatro veces en dos días
tendríamos que multiplicar estos
mililitros por por cuatro verdad pero
bueno ya con lo que hicimos hasta
ahorita resolvimos la pregunta que nos
hicieron que era la cantidad de
mililitros para el paciente por dosis
baja entonces espero que este vídeo te
haya aparecido interesante y sobre todo
que le ayude a los enfermeros por ahí a
hacer conversiones de unidades para dar
las dosis correctas y sobre todo si yo
soy su paciente y bueno por qué no
también a los médicos verdad también los
médicos es bueno que sepan convertir
unidades